welcome to other famous Friday I believe
whatever goal you have whatever
obstacles in front of you the easiest
way to accomplish it is to model success
find someone who's already overcome that
problem apply their strategies to make
it work for you so today's lesson is
from Chris Gardner who went from being a
homeless man to being a
multi-millionaire and his lesson is
don't quit so Chris Gardner
he had everything stacked against him
when he was growing up he didn't know
who his father was he was in and out of
foster homes because his mother was in
and out of prison she had tried to set
fire to her house with Chris Gardner
stepfather inside and so she was
arrested for it Chris Gardner didn't
have any positive male role models
growing up and so he bounced from foster
home to foster home to foster home he
experimented in drugs and alcohol he had
every reason not to be successful right
everything was against him but he didn't
quit he wanted to rise up he wanted to
get out of that life that he had and
create something new for himself so he
took a job as a assistant in a medical
research lab and he was earning $8,000 a
year he got a girlfriend he had a son
and he found out that you know what
$8,000 a year the cyma not survive but
he didn't know what else to do he was
struggling because he had no education
no savings nobody told him what to do he
was just trying to get by
just trying to survive but the one thing
he knew was he wasn't going to quit his
life changed when he saw a man on the
street pull up in a Ferrari get out in a
really nice suit and he asked the man
what do you do for as a career and the
guy told him that he was a stockbroker
and from that second Chris Gardner
wanted to become a stockbroker the only
problem was he had no education
he had no contacts no connections he
didn't understand stocks he wasn't
investing in stocks he was older than
most of the people who are entering into
that field right now everything was
against him but he didn't quit
he started working with that stockbroker
just getting to know him and found out
that there were training positions at
his firm and so for the next couple
months he pushed off his job he canceled
meetings you cancel appointments to go
to these interviews trained to learn
about their training program he rocked
up $1,200 in parking tickets going to
the meetings and eventually finally
after months he was accepted into their
training program he's all excited
finally I made it right I beat the odds
I made it I'm into the training program
I'm sitting this new course of my life
this is awesome he shows up to work the
first day and the guy who hired him was
fired and he finds out that there's no
place for him at this firm he put
everything into it he quit his job after
learning who'd be accepted he quit his
job shows up and there's no job to go to
you think that's bottom right like how
can things get any worse well it got
worse because he was arrested because he
didn't pay his $1,200 in parking tickets
and the judge threw him in jail for 10
days that's not even the worst part he
comes home and his girlfriend had moved
out and took their son with her that's
the low of the low for Chris Gardner but
he still didn't quit where most people
that point may say I think the universe
is trying to send me a message he didn't
quit he kept going on his dream he found
another company that had a training
program he applied he got accepted to
the training program there was a problem
though it was unpaid he wasn't going to
make any money he'd have to work really
hard and wouldn't get paid anything he
didn't have any savings he didn't have
any rich uncles to rely on it was only
himself and then his girlfriend comes
back drops off their son and says he's
yours I don't want him anymore
I knew takes over full custody for his
son
so he's got no money coming in he's got
this training job he's got this son he's
got to look after and the only thing
that he has is he takes a small
part-time thing selling medical
equipment that earns him three to four
hundred dollars a month that's all he
has to survive and he had to make the
choice do I provide shelter for my son
or do I give him food and he chose food
and he bounced from shelter to shelter
to Church to wherever they would take
them in and he got up every morning I
was one of the first people to go to the
office for that training job it was one
of the last people to leave and where
most people who were doing sales calls a
great day might be a hundred calls Chris
Gardner's goal was 200 unheard of crazy
work ethic crazy productivity he woke up
got to the office pounded the calls
until everything was closed and then
went back and found whatever homeless
shelter would take him and his son where
most people would have quit long time
ago on their dream Chris Gardner kept
going even though he had every single
odds stacked against him and through the
perseverance through the work ethic
he made it through he got hired he
passed a training program he was able to
pull himself out of poverty then he
applied that same work ethic to
launching his own business and he grew
it he eventually sold it in a
multi-million dollar exit a lot of
people feel like they have the odds
stacked against them you may feel you
have the odds stacked against you and
you tell yourself I don't have the
resources I don't have the connections I
don't have the education I don't have
the money and you quit successful
entrepreneurs don't quit even though you
may have everything stacked against you
if you believe in your dream even when
it doesn't make sense if you believe in
it then you have to keep going don't
quit and it may lead to a multi-million
dollar exit for you to owe and that
Ferrari that Chris Gardner loves so much
he ended up buying his own Ferrari
bought it from Michael Jordan and
changed the license plate to not MJ
believe if you guys liked this video you
want to see more just like it subscribe
to the channel thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon if you want
some believe in your inbox every week to
keep you motivated check out the link
below to join my newsletter